thank you Mike Jamal that big three on
your favorite play when they were making
a run in the fourth quarter how were you
able to hold it down when Nikola was on
the bench in foul trouble how about my
teammates teammates are great
um A.G Kane Bruce
yo Jeff came in the game CV I mean
everybody was today was a team effort I
can't even name one person everybody
locked in
um we got one more to go tonight you
made history became the first person in
NBA history to have at least 10 assists
in their first four finals games what
does that mean to you like I said my
teammates you don't get assist without
them making shots and I'm making the
right read so
to my teammates they did a great job
there's a great team effort on both
bands and we got we gotta do that for
one more game and we get our goal we
started to name names but I want to
single out some guys Aaron Gordon
Describe the impact he had on this game
he just uh played with confidence today
you know he saw one go down
um we're just trying to stay aggressive
you know he did that going in the room
making shots Gordon zimby uh being on
the boards just you know being a forest
like he was in game one and uh you know
tonight was him how about Bruce Brown
his 21 points Off the Bench I mean Bruce
kahoop I guess we gotta we gotta a bunch
of guys that can come in the game impact
and uh you can't just focus on me or
yolk you got to guard everybody and
tonight just was another example Jamal
you have told us that being on this
stage is all you have ever dreamed about
as a kid now you're one game away from a
championship how do you close this thing
out on Monday just stay level-headed
stay focused and then when we get that
dub then we can then we can relax and we
can talk a little yeah yeah we'll talk
more all right I'll see you on Monday
all right Lisa well we said after the
game three Victory here in Miami that
was the biggest win in franchise history
there's a new one to hold the title game
four has them up now three games to one